Justin what was your breaking point the
lowest moment with killing Winston Jones
where you came close to quitting that's
a great question I don't know the exact
point to be honest I think as writers we
work our best to bury some of the
difficult moments and try to remember
the positive moments a little bit more
to be optimistic and excited about you
know the potential of what we're working
on but offhand I would say probably the
third and final time that we lost
financing I just think that Joel and I
our director Joel and I had put in so
much time and effort into getting this
script where it needed to be and we put
in you know two years of our life
non-stop and really exhausted our
resources at that point I think we were
just feeling beaten down we'd worked so
hard especially with this last
production company where the financing
fell through so I think I that was the
hardest moment just because I felt like
if I wasn't the cheerleader anymore
everyone else could potentially walk
away and even the producers that we had
at that point that we're working on
other projects or some of the actors
that said that they would you know that
were verbally attached I could just see
that it looked like it was at a place
where it could potentially fall apart
and this the toughest part also is that
getting back to what we were talking
about with packaging is that when you do
package a film that package so often
changes because you can get an
incredible actor who's attached
themselves but if they're a great actor
chances are they're on a lot of
different projects and their schedules
change so I knew that some of the great
actors that we had you know the interest
from Dreyfuss and the interest from
Glover and and from Masterson and Heeter
and everybody else was limited and if we
weren't gonna be able to get it done
this year chances were we were gonna
lose all of you know most if not all of
those actors and so I think that was the
toughest point I think if you asked my
wife she could probably tell you more
specific
because you know your significant other
has to live with you through those
moments those moments that you're
extremely excited about but also those
moments where you're kind of at the
bottom so yeah I would say it's probably
when we lost the financing for the third
and final time and little did I know
that you know 48 hours later we got
financing we were going into
pre-production so in that 24th hour
before you knew maybe I don't and I much
for the exact timeline but how did you
kind of pick yourself up what was your
self-talk knowing that you were sort of
like the patriarch of the family you you
know you're trying to hold it together
and if your mood sours then it takes it
all down I think you have to find
distractions and find outlets and things
you know I think it's healthy to have
outlets in any capacity in life you know
I'm a writer first and foremost but
that's not all that you know I'm known
for that I want to be known for that I
want to do you know I I also you know I
love you know seeing movies I love
listening to music I love you know
painting I love reading I love all these
other things so I think really at my
worst moments I'm probably distracting
myself with something else that is at
least making me happy
but I don't think that I ever really
completely gave up I don't think you can
give up the people who give up aren't in
the industry anymore they're not writing
anymore you know you don't you don't
give up on projects you keep pushing
them through I mean the projects that I
don't have success with that don't end
up making it onto the screen till the
day I die I'll still be pushing them and
trying to make them on the screen you
know I'll never shelve something and
never go back to it so I think there's a
time and a place for everything and you
know I I think that I still am fighting
for killing with some jealousy you know
there's still challenges that we have to
go through I I can't say that there
won't be another time when maybe I think
that the film isn't gonna make it in the
theaters or isn't gonna get accepted in
the film festivals there's gonna be
tragic moments along the way and
difficult moments along the way too but
it's just staying positive so
I think that you allow yourself to have
those moments where you feel the
depression and you feel upset about the
bad things that have happened but know
that you can easily climb out of that
and it's something that I said before
about distractions with other projects
you know killing Weston Jones was
difficult because I had all my eggs in
one basket that point because I hadn't
really written a lot of other things but
now that I have you know two other
features I have a short that I'm
adapting I have a TV show that I'm
working on like those there's always at
least one thing good that's happening to
keep me positive you know and or
something on the horizon at least so I
think that there's no reason to always
or to ever be down completely
no something should be able to lift you
up and get you out of that and you know
that 24th hour past and we were flying
you know on the next flight out to
Savannah Georgia to make the movie so
you know and that's and that's what I
remember that's why this question was
hard to answer because I can't remember
the lowest point because it's replaced
by you know working on set with Dreyfuss
you know or learning about acting and
writing from Danny Glover and his
experiences or having dinner with the
entire you know crew almost every night
that we were there and those
relationships we built so those easily
replace the difficult times
you